the waist should be fine should be
fighting a fundamentalist ideology
whether they're doing it or not is
another story first of all I think well
partly if you were dealing with someone
but like Osama bin Laden I know that the
fight is military apart from that it
shouldn't be you know I I was very much
against the war any rot before it
happened apart from the fact that I had
lived in Iran and I knew how disastrous
it will be for my country which it was
because the most extreme elements within
this system got into Iraq and they also
got to suppress the Iranian people far
more and every time you talk about
democracy they say you are an American
stooge so for us if we pay the price but
I think if the West doesn't understand
that what the fundamentalists are afraid
of is the culture of democracy what is
it that they object to freedom of women
freedom of expression freedom of
minorities freedom of culture all of
this is what Osama bin Laden is saying
calling the West decadent the way Stalin
used to call wheres decadent for these
issues so these are your strong points
if you're fighting you fight with
culture you fight with ideology if
you're fighting people who torture that
their own people and others you don't do
the same thing so the West I feel should
be very careful of not becoming cynical
of its own values what threatens the
West is partly radical Islam or
radicalism partly the fear of terror but
the most threat to the West is seen it
cynicism about its own values and
principles and that I think is what
threatens the West
well because of this polarization first
of all the same way that people keep
talking about what is genuine authentic
Islam you'll find this in America
nowadays who is the authentic American
you know will the authentic American
please stand up the mists of and it is
the most against simplified mythology
like they talk about values mr. Huckabee
talks a lot about family values and an
American values was American values it
always values against gays I mean that
is how this country was founded we're
fighting women's rights and Anna and gay
rights or was American values based on
life liberty and pursuit of happiness I
felt that if you want to use a great
American myth you use the myth that this
is a country based on an impossibility
this is a country that came here and
said we'll create something that has not
existed you know so it is the country of
the future in a sense and it is a
country where that is why it allows
people like me to still come and make
the same claims you know that I can do
something I could never do you know and
and these are American values for me to
reduce it to this disgusting talk that
American values are about protecting our
children from you know gays and lesbians
and I'm sorry I keep saying that but
that keeps coming up to my mind as
something so narrow and just disturbing
you know and by the way I tell Americans
and I was saying that last night
actually at the meeting if Americans
feel that it is beneath their dignity
that waterboarding and censorship in
this country hurts their values why
don't they think that this hurts my
value
as a Persian why don't they think some
people on the left why don't they think
that they should support human rights of
Iranians or F Bonnie's or Iraqis right
now how many people on the left are
coming out and saying Iraqi women cannot
leave home if they leave home without
the veil they'll be killed Iraqi
minorities are killed the street where
Iraqis had their bookstores has gone up
in flames why don't they support the
Iranian women who are right now asking
for 1 million signatures against the
repressive laws in Iran why don't they
why do they ask President Bush to
condemn Saudi Arabia but they don't come
out against idea Arabia in the streets
you know these are the questions that I
think the myth of the West if you guys
have those values you talk about why are
you concerned about connecting your
values to others why is it that coming
to me it's my culture to to wear the
veil but it is not your culture because
harriet beecher stowe when she was
fighting they were telling her that
Bible says that the woman's place is at
home those women in 19th century were
not feted and they were called blue
stockings in as a derogatory term
Elizabeth Cady Stanton did not live to
see women gain their rights to vote
which was only in 1924 it's not still a
hundred years you know so I'm sorry am I
going I mean you can always edit this so
what I'm saying about these mythologies
is depending upon whose mythology you
choose I choose the the Declaration of
Independence Smith and and i think that
the wonderful thing about America people
keep saying we have a woman and an
african-american now running for
presidency which is wonderful but think
that we say that would surprise which
means that it's no surprise to me why
shouldn't a woman or an african-american
be the candidate for the greatest
democracy in the
world but we have come a long way but
not long enough to begin with and the
second thing is that the best thing
about this country is that it can change
it can stretch its laws so the woman who
in 19th century had to stay at home at
in 21st century can run for the highest
office so a man that in 19th century
would be working in the fields as a
slave it can now become the president of
this country Martin Luther King's dream
was not just the dream you know this is
the myth that I'm after that is why
sometimes i think obama is giving us the
the right message
you